Master Hunter world's first the
expansion ice-born brings a ton of new
content in the game for you to sink your
teeth into but as is usual with Monster
Hunter the game doesn't always do the
best job of explaining everything to you
we've compiled the best advice that we
would have found helpful when first
starting up ice-born Osbourne's biggest
addition in combat is the clutch claw
and it's a real game changer when you
aim your slinger with the left trigger
which you can now do with your weapons
still drawn you can fire your clutch
claw at a monster and grapple on to its
body from there you have several options
first you can attack the monster and
inflict damage to this specific part
you're on have you weapons like the
charged blade or switch axe will soften
that part of the monster leaving it
susceptible to further damage for a
short period this is very useful for
monsters with heavy armor that can
easily deflect your attacks on the other
hand lighter weapons like dual blades or
the bow can't soften body parts but
instead will cause swinger ammo to drop
aside from attacking with your weapon
wall clutched you can also use a claw
attack when clutched to the monsters
head to force it to change directions
you'll want to use this to reposition
the monster and then hit it with the
flinch shots this attack can only be
used when you have slinger ammo the
attack will unload all of your ammo and
then send the monster flying backwards
if they hit a wall the monster will fall
over leaving it vulnerable the clutch
claw is a fantastic tool for setting up
weak points or toppling over a monster
for big damage it can specifically
change up the way you approach a fight
so don't forget to take advantage of its
functionality
in ice-born the clutch claw isn't the
only new addition to your arsenal every
weapon type has been given new moves for
example the switch axes axe mode comes
with a new heavy slam that powers it up
making axe mode more powerful for
dealing damage where before you might
have just stuck with sword mode it's
worth spending time learning the new
moves for your weapon of choice in the
training area you can check out the
weapon controls in the hunter notes new
button inputs are listed in the light
gray text and new modes and combos are
listed in blue the game is still not the
clearest when it comes to telling you
how to implement these new moves in
combat so you might want to spend extra
time practicing to better understand how
they work
[Music]
but maybe after spending hours of
mastering your weapon of choice in the
base game you might be interested in
learning a new weapon well don't worry
because the ore and bone trees for each
weapon have a new rank 9 version you can
craft these more powerful versions line
up nicely with the difficulty at the
beginning of ice-born and might even be
better than your current weapon it also
helps that they're simple to make
requiring some quick farming in the
master rank versions of expeditions
your pal ko is no longer the only one
that can use monsters as tail Raiders
simply activate raider ride from your
item bar to summon your own mount
however you cannot control the monster
directly set a destination on the
wildlife map and your tail Raider will
automatically travel there if you don't
set a destination it will begin
following nearby tracks tail Raiders are
not only a great way to quickly track
down a monster but you can still pick up
tracks grab materials or even use items
while riding them so heal up sharpen
your weapon or do whatever you need to
do while your tail Raider deals with the
navigation once you reach your
destination you can either dismount
normally or hop into the fray with a
jumping attack which is a great way to
start off any fight
[Music]
iceborn introduces master rank a new
tier of difficulty above high rank and
is this games equivalent to the series
notorious top tier G rank difficulty
everything in the ice-born dlc is master
rank but there are also new master rank
versions of the previous biomes and all
the older monsters outside of being more
difficult and offering new materials
there are more subtle differences in
master rank although the game doesn't
make them clear up front for example
using flash pods repeatedly on monsters
causes them to slowly build up a
tolerance reducing the stun duration
each time they're used until they
eventually become immune the resistance
does eventually go away over time but we
recommend pacing out how often use flash
pods and maybe don't give your palico
the flash black age older monsters also
seem to have new attacks in master rank
we noticed the tobe kodachi has a new
lightning state it enters during a fight
but there are also other monsters that
seem to behave the same as they do in
the base game we haven't had a chance to
thoroughly test out every old monster so
we can't give you a definitive breakdown
but it's something worth keeping in mind
a minor but important change to know is
how monsters behave when near death they
still head back to their nest asleep
however they will no longer fall asleep
if you're present so when a monster
starts to head back pause and give them
a sec to get ahead of you so they can
still fall asleep giving you ample
opportunity to safely capture or get the
jump on them
when progressing through ice-born you
might not notice that your old palico
equipment can now be upgraded to higher
proficiency levels leveling them
increases their effectiveness but there
are also new abilities and changes for
example the plunder blade can now pull
four materials off a monster at a time
the biggest change however is to the
vigor wasp spray which can now be used
to revive you that's right if you lose
all your health your palico can save you
with a bigger wasp and prevent you from
carting it's worth noting that this new
perk can only be used once per hunt so
you still want to exercise caution
[Music]
the Steamworks is a new minigame you can
play at cell iana by matching the hidden
sequence of buttons you can build up
these steam meter and earn items
[Music]
it's random so don't stress out what
you'll get and just try your luck
although there are moments when the Pala
codes will give you hints in order to
use the Steamworks you'll need to fill
it with fuel you'll earn fuel by
completing quests or trading in items
eventually the fuel will hit a cap and
when that happens it's time to play the
minigame and empty it out you'll
naturally acquire more fuel as you play
so just remember to check in on the
Steamworks from time to time to win free
items this tip isn't necessarily new to
ice-born but it's an important reminder
to not just focus on the main missions
and to do your optional quests as well
specifically the ones that bank you
unique rewards there are further
upgrades to be made at the canteen more
space for your harvest box and upgrades
to mantels just to name a few but a new
type of reward you'll earn from optional
quests are decorations for your house
and cell iana so if you're really into
home to quorum do those quests those are
all the tips we think are helpful to
know when you start playing monster
hunter world ice-born if you find any
additional helpful tips once you start
playing the game please put them in the
comments and let us know if there's
anything specific you want us to cover
for ice-born such as a more detailed
breakdown of master rank differences or
how ice boards and game works thanks for
watching